volunteer evacuation driver igor kamenev
listens to directions from a contact on
the front line
there will be a petrol station you go
straight and after the crossroads you
turn right she says
we put on our protective vests and get
on the bus
it's an hour's drive to the town of
abdivika through countryside that so far
doesn't bear the scars of war
eagles church group got a call that up
to 40 people wanted to be evacuated
immediately
he has to move fast because there's been
a lull in the shelling
we feel we have to do something because
people have to live it's as simple as
that when we go in we are very anxious
but when we get people out we feel joy
destroyed buildings begin to appear as
we enter town the bus stops and we walk
down into a nearby bunker
orlando fled shelling around the town of
krematorsk with her two daughters yeva
and maria
she says she is too afraid to leave the
relative safety of the underground
shelter
the children are terrified of the
shelling shells are hitting buildings
near our home it's not as loud
underground
the streets above are virtually empty
russian shells have hit residential
housing blocks nearby
people start boarding the bus
some have brought their pets
sisters moms and dads and the elderly
this terrified old lady told us i'm so
scared and i don't want to die
i feel great relief we lived for more
than a month in the basement we are just
so thankful it's very scary we just have
to leave
the bus races out of town before the
shelling starts again
this is the first time that the church
group has received a call from people
desperately wanting to get out of
amdivka
these evacuees now face a three-day
journey
to a shelter in western ukraine there
are ongoing evacuation efforts to
various villages and towns happening
across eastern ukraine but they are not
negotiated by the un or agreed upon by
russian forces
there is no safe passage for thousands
of people like these
child staff at al jazeera abdivka
eastern ukraine